[Musique]
à
je vous présente votre nouveau collègue
silva salue attendait y'a que ça que
meuf la wii alors choisi n'est pas trop
belle comme ça ça déconcentre personnes
je vous rassure on n'est pas déstabilisé
par les mecs n'ont plus l'âge est
engagée sylvain parce que son père avec
qui je joue au golf me l'a demandé et je
le laisse maintenant se présenter à vous
va donc salut je m'appelle sylvain j'ai
deux passions dans la vie la randonnée
et la masturbation et
professionnellement j'ai fait un peu de
com digitales et de bloemfontein les
points ont été au chômage bingo c'est ça
le monde c'est le chômage
vous allez travailler ensemble tous les
deux ok mais à mon avis c'est un escroc
1 en plus j'étais debout ses envies nos
patrons moi j'ai pas d'amis j'adore
parler et j'adore les binômes voilà je
l'espère connaissance à moi je vais me
taper une petite sieste dans mon bureau
je te préviens pu prendre toutes les
idées je vais faire croire ces lignes n
ya pas de soucis mais moi comme je bosse
à la dernière minute tu vas te faire
griller dis moi tu peux ne pas me
toucher je peux squatter chez toi entre
trois semaines et six mois pourquoi tu
veux ou là je suis chez mon cousin mais
ça marche c'est une tare et sous
prétexte que je me balade la flûte
allait répéter des crises ouais faut
mettre des slips au ciel donc vu que
j'ai pu d'appart je me disais si toi tu
es un canapé un bol de kawa une douche
ah bah moi je crache pas dessus
non j'ai pas envie ouais je comprends
j'aurais fait pareil
attends tu m'as déjà ajoutés sur
facebook oui comme ça on est
officiellement avait maintenant on se
connaît depuis cinq minutes arrête je
vais être obligé d'accepter sinon je
vais passer pour un an qu il m était
relou bon allez on s'y remet à temps il
est 11h30 d'accord tu veux boire un
petit café je fais des blagues à la
machine je me lave un peu les mains par
erreur de bouffer donc en gros moi je
fais tout et toi tu fruits ab c'est le
principe du binôme voilà
on est complémentaires bono
didier carreaux aller
[Applaudissements]